[Musique]
après sept mois d'incarcération à la
prison de la santé jean luc lahaye libre
jean luc lahaye 69 ans n'a pas dormi en
prison la nuit dernière le chanteur des
années 80 était accusé depuis le 3
novembre dernier de viol et d'agressions
sexuelles sur deux mineurs de 15 et 17
ans le chanteur jean-luc lahaye a été
mis en examen pour viols et agressions
sexuelles sur deux adolescentes state au
début au début des années 2010 des faits
remontant à 2013 qui prouve en heatley
s'apparentaient à des relations
consenties les échanges intime qu'il ait
eu entre elle et moi était passé ses 15
ans de toute manière je la sens
détention provisoire il avait aussi de
déposer une demande de remise en liberté
désormais sous contrôle judiciaire jean
luc lahaye doit cependant respecter
plusieurs conditions résister à paris
bercy une caution de 20 mille euros ne
pas entrer en contact avec d'autres
protagonistes du dossier et pointer dans
un commissariat
tous les quinze jours les décisions que
certains approuvent pas alors accusé de
viols et d'agressions sur mineurs
comprenez vous que jean luc lahaye soit
déjà libre
merci et dominique richer ami proche de
john & clyde être avec nous merci
dominique pourre soir 1 0
annie proche de jean luc lahaye est
vraiment car j'adore ça l'envers des
affaires c'est incroyable ça ça ça voilà
ça très fort ça il faut qu'on fasse des
choses ça il faut qu'on le voit ça c'est
voilà il faut l'adapter à croire mais
c'est moi je suis fou de ça mais c'est
je regarde crime tous les lundis
enquêtes criminelles le mardi
et le dimanche je me suicide
c'est vrai ça on va parler donc de la
faire jean luc lahaye
merci dominique d'être là aujourd'hui
donc jean luc est sorti de prison vous
l'avez ou pas non j'ai eu deux personnes
proches de jean luc nous sommes très
contents ses proches ses amis ce le
public et des milliers de personnes qui
sont heureux cette fois c'est énormément
c'était très long mais je pense qu'en
trois semaines un mois il aurait pu
régler le problème c'est une affaire
vieille à 5 ans qui ressortit on l'a
traîné dans la boue c'est honteux on le
traite de prédateurs prédateur c'est les
gens qui témoignent ses portes pour vous
voilà moi j'aimerais bien voir la vision
d'un de ses amis sur cette affaire c'est
quoi expliquer à nos téléspectateurs
tous les artistes comme toutes les
personnes connues ils sont approchés par
des milliers de personnes les gens
viennent le voir vous pouvez pas
demander à tout le monde d'une pièce
d'identité bon il a il est des rapports
avec deux filles il a été condamné à dix
mille balles à l'époque il ya cinq ans
ça ressort sur le tapis et avec dédé des
choses hors durieux ce que j'ai pu lire
dans les journaux et ça ça me fait de la
peine pour lui il a c'est quand même un
petit café une acteur qui est sorti de
la rue c'est un enfant de la rue il a
pas eu de père il n'a pas eu de famille
il s'est fait tout seul il a fait sa
carrière de chanteur il a créé un club
de piètres de parachutistes à xhoffraix
toi il a créé sans famille c'est quand
même un type responsable qu'il est en
vie de jeune fille c'est pas le seul il
ya plein d'artistes qui sont les défis
briquets non
tu peux pas dire ça
c'est choquant non mais c'est pas de
questions nancy est là ils savaient pas
ils savaient pas quelle avec un si jeune
si jeune il s'est fait un peu berner bon
il m'a dit dans les villes et les
victimes oui et des victimes et quand
vous dites moi si je vous dis que j'ai
70 ans alors que j'en ai 64 vous n'êtes
pas obligés de me croire j'avais 15 ans
en l'occurrence mais ils elles se font
passer pour des gamins de 18 ans voire
plus donc fois je suis en tournée je
vois les gaming j'ai travaillé beaucoup
d'artistes j'ai fait beaucoup de
tournées j'ai assisté plein ça soit du
chanteur gay qui sont attirés par l'ine
fans bien venez voir où des femmes
veulent coucher avec x chanteur qui est
août et c'est la loi qui est comme ça on
vient les voir les gens ça fait rêver
d'un artiste nom des gens des problèmes
suivants
06 et moi on est là on est en 2022 ce
que vous me décrivez c'est des années 70
c'est que l'autre en soi et ce alors la
bombe était clos 30 ans
ils vont respirer jeunes par l'acquéreur
de cloclo qui s'est dit moi aussi je
pourrais avoir des petites 12 13 ans qui
viennent devant la porte avec qui je
fais les choses peut recommander 13 ans
et non mais bon donc il ya quand même si
vous voulez ce garçon je pense qu'il est
un peu le melon qui croit qu'on est
toujours dans les années 70 80 et en
réalité ça ne se fait plus ça fait des
années qu'on lutte pour essayer d'en
finir avec la pédocriminalité or c'est
ce qu'on assimile à de la
pédocriminalité même s'il ya des filles
qui viennent vous dites qu'ils sont
consentantes et un homme ça s'empêche on
dit il n'est pas obligé de se jeter sur
elle qui prennent des femmes plus âgées
ce chèque ou des semaines il a 69 ans il
y a deux très belle femme de 69 ans mais
qui ne soit pas comme ça à vouloir
absolument de la jeunesse ou alors c'est
parce que lui même n'a pas évolué dans
sa tête il a toujours 15 ans et un
enfant et donc dans ce cas là c'est
psychiatrique menée le nombre de ceux
d'artistes qui sont avec des jeux des
femmes beaucoup plus jeune que
ce que dit ce que dit dominique il dit
qu'il ne savait pas quel âge de la vie
je me fais draguer je vais vous dire un
truc quand je suis avec les artistes
soit avec jean-luc ou d'autres jeux tout
saute sur plusieurs personnalités du
showbiz
les gars me dadié de me voir je suis pas
là avec une carte d'identité mois pour
slogan je vous dis un truc quand j'étais
gamin j'avais 20 ans j'en disais vous le
t-shirt d'être faut toucher la bête
voilà c'est comme ça que j'ai réussi un
oui quand même je faisais gaffe mais oui
mais marc dont je rêve à force ou est
actuaire coq sur la [ __ ] ou sera foot
pour savoir avec qui on va comment on
fait
mais géra disney sas également
l'évolution justement où vous ne trouvez
pas ça choquant qu'une corde à noeuds
ruine hommes qu'ils soient fans sous
seing privé ou elle soit devenu une
sorte de best-of sexuelle de jean luc
lahaye envie de savoir un truc est ce
que les gens sont ouverts avant de venir
sur le plateau
[Applaudissements]
incroyable ça
en fait envoyé je veux bien non tout si
on tombe dessus c'est ça c'est rigolo à
lagraulas 160 mille enfants un nageur
qui souffre de violence sexuelle chaque
année en france ont 70% des affaires
sont classées sans suite la honte n'est
quelqu'un il est connu donc hilal au
large et prend pour les autres leur
maître aujourd'hui en liberté ça me
paraît quand même un signal qu'on donne
à tous les gens qui ont des tendances
pédophiles pédocriminels de dire voyez
vous passez quelques mois en cabane on
vous remet dehors et vous pouvez
recommencer c'est ça que ça veut dire et
ça tombe mal surtout en ce moment avec
toutes les affaires qui arrivent
tous les jours
l'impression qui a remis ses 200 ans et
comme bonus on sent des bouleaux bien
celui-là la feci suit la milice et pour
ça
ces sept mois sept mois c'est à ceux-là
contre live donc faire changer
c'est moi mais on peut surveiller les
sites est monsieur on peut se faire que
se féliciter qu'effectivement ça ces
histoires sortent et qu'auparavant elle
était étouffé enfouis c'est parce que un
talent étaient célèbres ou tel autre
avec des cliniques succès d'artistes
louche avec une fille de 15 ans qui
s'est déclaré avoir 18 ans et le salir
le traîner parce que je suis regardé
votre émission au niveau du mois de
novembre et vous l'avez certains ici ou
là était né dans la boue avec des choses
ignobles quand on regarde dans les
journaux ce qui était écrit c'est la
france c'est le deuxième qui était là
pour savoir ce qui a marqué qu il
faisait si on faisait ça il faut
attendre il va y aura justement le jour
qui sera relaxé on sera il ya des lits
qui lie la jat embêter avec charge de
ces années même personne ce sont les
mêmes personnes aux questions un peu on
peut aussi s'interroger en se demandant
si la justice justement voulu de cette
c'est une histoire qui date c'est la
justice revient sur ces faits et si
jean-luc l'arrêt a été justement
incarcéré le temps de l'enquète c'est
donc qu'il y avait quelque chose pour
que la justice décide pense qu'avec un
bois c'était suffisant
car c'en est aujourd'hui est sorti de
prison donc jean luc lahaye il va qu'est
ce qui va se passer là au bon là il va
se passer rien du tout il va rester chez
lui il ira tous les quinze jours
pointent au commissariat et puis c'est
tout et puis va attendre paisiblement
son procès ne sera pas surveillé
spécialement le soir quand il ira en
boîte ils risquent de recommencer en
réalité mais après c'est moi je veux pas
le traîner dans la boue comme disait
monsieur jean luc lahaye jean luc lahaye
bon c'est un peu une enfin une vedette
d'autres fois il est sympa il est
marrant admettons maintenant le fait
qu'on remette maintenant liberté c'est
c'est véritablement une très mauvaise
idée au niveau de la justice mais parce
que ça veut dire continuez les gars on
regarde ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé que
ce qu'on a appris hier ce monsieur qui
s'appelle bouthier j'ai suivi cette
affaire là
président d'air directeur général de
assu 2000 une des 500 plus grosses
fortunes de france qu'est ce qu'ils
faisaient ce gala
il avait assuré cette fille pendant des
années des mineurs qui se relayaient à
qui sait les
bons ils pouvaient évidemment faire
l'amour et qu'elle en échange elle avait
un petit appart et il a voulu répudier
la dernière qui avait 22 ans il a dit tu
la remplace par une copine à toi de 14
ans est ce qui était trop vieille parce
que t'es trop vieille et on est et tout
ça et après comme celle qu'a 22 ans qui
répudie a filmé la scène entre ce type
quand même 75 ans est la fille de 14 ans
il a monté une équipe lebouthillier avec
un ex du gign avec sa femme et de deux
acolytes qui traînent dans sa boîte pour
aller retirer la vidéo à la fille aînée
c'est de la force et de s'enfuir hors de
france on est dans un système là on est
dans un réseau donc ça c'est encore
infiniment plus grave qu'un sur les
agissements de jean luc lavoie ça n'a
rien à voir mais ce qui est important et
ça c'est quand tu veux dire sur toute
personne qui aujourd'hui fait des
erreurs dans ce domaine à soi évidemment
prises et punis donc c'est pour ça que
ça tombe mal que ton ami jean-luc soit
libéré aujourd'hui que tu veux tu qu'on
balance et un truc spécial c'est que le
chanteur évoque une vengeance
éventuellement oui
c'est bien que je pense qu'ils lui ont
fait payer le fait tech des allusions
qu'il a fait ou vers le couple
présidentiel puisque ses terres la cct
relaté dans les journaux en disant que
le président elle était avec une fille
beaucoup plus âgées que kia nuit à
l'époque si vous lisez les journaux
quand on voit tout ce qui a été écrit
c'est quoi le rapport c'est un grand
complot en fait elles rapport à
l'histoire de mélo on
fait passer les présumées victimes pour
elle justement elle elle qui seraient
des prédatrices contre ce pauvre jean
luc lahaye alors moi je veux bien je ne
suis pas dans le dossier d'instruction
je ne sais pas c'est bon ça encore une
fois monsieur il ya deuxième deux jeunes
femmes et l est pas et elle est maman de
ces jeunes mamans canton et l'histoire
les mamans c'est aussi qui visiblement
est monté il se retrouve en prison et
elle a signé il ya la fille de jean luc
lahaye qui a été inquiétée également
voilà donc
on peut pas non plus dire il ne se passe
rien circulez ya rien à voir je ne sais
pas mais se passe visiblement quelque
chose est quelque chose qui n'est pas
joli son groom a réussi à obtenir pour
les femmes on est en train d'obtenir
pour les femmes on voudrait l'obtenir
pour les mineurs pour les enfants c'est
un travail de la semaine on a du mal
avec les différents gouvernements les
enfants se détournent du système quand
il fait quand la gamine de 16 ans rentre
en discothèque moi j'ai ma copine sa
fille elle a chopé en train de voir des
shots là dans 10 cas en plus de ce fait
fi mais surtout sur instagram les
gamines elles rendent partout 10 10 à 16
17 ans et ben je suis juste là est la
cible est comme tous les artistes on est
là monsieur pour dire à ces gens femmes
à ces jeunes filles faites attention
réseaux sociaux vous savez qu'il ya des
fausses influence euse qui existent qui
sont en fait des mecs on a consacré une
enquête au coeur du x puisque elle se
retrouve dans le porno
cette semaine voilà c'est donc à un
garçon en l'occurrence qui s'appelle
julien 40 ans deux enfants il se fait
passer pour axel influenceurs sexy sur
le sur les réseaux les jeunes filles
deviennent amis avec ce julien alias
axel et puis un jour il dit bon je vois
tu es dans la galère après des mois
parce qu'elle dise oui je gagne pas
d'argent ceci je rêve de si jeune âge
est un moyen pour te fais garde gagner
un peu d'argent rends-toi à reims à thé
ferait dans telle ou telle à tes frais
et là tu feras l'amour avec un mec tu
auras 3000 euros y a quand même dit
fille qu'ils ont fait ok et septembre
qui les arrange et des camions de dieu à
cette affaire-là ils sont interrompus
entendu bol on a ressenti cette affaire
c'est qu'on va terminer mon histoire et
donc ses filles se retrouvent là
évidemment c'est julien qui est là la
fameuse influence 2 et finalement ils
ont pas les 3000 euros sombre histoire
le coursier qui devait apporter l'argent
n'apportait pas l'argent elle rend ce
tristement chez eve est là qu est ce qui
se passe elle se confie à qui axel via
les réseaux sociaux 1 et alors elle dit
ah bah alors j'ai une autre solution oui
c'est vrai ça n'est jamais arrivé je
t'assure je ne comprends pas du tout ce
plan normalement ça marchait toujours
alors donc ce que tu vas faire
maintenant je sais que tu vas venir
faire du porno ça sera moins bien payés
ça sera plus que 500 euros et elle se
retrouve là en des vidéos pornos et donc
c'est un système il faut alerter vous et
quand émission regardée par les jeunes
soeurs fo les salariés en leur disant
attention à ces soi-disant
d'influenceurs à san luis génial serait
en fait c'est bien souvent des mecs qui
ont pas du tout une ville géniale qui
veulent un vous sautez de jamais vous
file est une et trois vous mettre dans
le porno juste aujourd'hui monique jean
luc les dents dans quelles dispositions
là il va apprendre à se requinquer il
est sorti amaigri de de sept mois
il va aller vivre dans un endroit où on
va pouvoir se refaire la cerise et puis
je lui souhaite et nous nous souhaitons
le public souhaite qu'ils retournent sur
les tournées et qu'on revoie la
télévision et tout ça et puis qu'il soit
relaxé une deuxième fois lors de cette
affaire et puis c'est tout vu je suis
fille il a tout dit une deuxième fois
relax m deuxième fois que c'est pas
l'affairé en 2007 monsieur samu 15 ans
il a déjà fait des conneries avec une
mineure de moins de 15 ans et recommence
encore aujourd'hui comme a dit karzaï
s'est adjugé à
faire tomber les sacs dia 7 ans et elle
ressort aujourd'hui cette monsieur
écouter 15 ya quinze jours après après
après je veux dire comme vous dites
c'est il faut savoir que l'époque à a
changé alors quand vous dites nous
ferons peut s'en réjouir la bébête avant
de toucher la ve net à ses fonds non
c'était pour moi pour draghi à l'époque
c'est moi les filles base elle voulait
tous rentrés avec la cepap j'étais
subjugué de toutes ces femmes et ces
hommes qui le désert hague et même avant
d'ailleurs avant et même maintenant ça
c'est assez incroyable énormément de
gens qui sont il ya 40 ans en arrière
c'était une simplicité de couche avec
les gens y avaient passé maladie qu'on a
déjà aujourd'hui
changer je parle pas des dessins des
dangers toubal 10 les femmes adultes qui
venaient me voir pour rencontrer avis y
voir comme les artistes moi je parle pas
de mineure mais attention je parle des
jantes maintenant jean luc aro
vous l'avez ça c'est sa vie comme ça il
faudra
bien sûr j'ai regardé au mois de
novembre c'est lui qui a mis en examen
oui bien sûr oui jusqu'à temps qu'il
soit jugé s'est mis tout seul dans
l'isère six en tout cas merci d'avoir
été avec nous merci dominique mercy
également karl zéro l'envers des
affaires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]